hello and welcome to this video playing
grand master medela
2019 i only recently
played this person
i don't quite remember the game actually
i remember i won yeah we see i actually
i can click on that
ah okay
yeah i remember there was a fiance uh
nimzo
where black okay so we have a
pretty much un-theoretical position here
let's take
okay a simple way to handle
something like that is to just build a
hedgehog
and i'm going to do that here the white
setup
is not very aggressive and the hedgehog
is a pretty much
solid way to counter that so let's do it
the pure hedgehog is d6 knight bd7 i
could do that
knight is pretty good on c5
knight c5
yeah this is an interesting move i i was
thinking it could be too weakening but
yeah it's not it's not clear cut at all
knight a4 there's a three
and then i have a5 i mean
i don't want to go to a6 and it looks
really
wrong so a5
the important thing about this position
is compared to
others there's no knight on c3 so
that's a different thing compared to
positions where you go a5 and b5
is weak it's not really happening here
currently i'm just attacking that pawn
yeah this looks like a good reply
actually
queen d8 is the
ambitious move
keeping b4 attacked
queen c6 that is a very
that looks very dicey in a way
i don't see why it wouldn't work though
i don't want to go back and d6s
i'd like to have this pressure on
and i definitely would like to see him
playing b5
b5 queen c5 i think i have good chances
to simply win the a3 born
and he cannot move the knight on yeah on
on a good square like this because
made on g2 so it's not happening
bishop c2 i have night
and night move knight c3
knight c3 bishop h7 check is possible
but
i will win before at the end
i don't see how he's handling this on
the queen side it doesn't
just look good for me
even though it's it has a shaky quality
and my position my queen for example
has absolutely no square to go to
and there could be some tactical flaw
something like let's say c5
something like that something really
really
tactical but c5 i can actually take
b4 right i can take b form and then c5
okay so he went for this move let's see
um
i would like to take here
first i mean he cannot take on b6 i have
queen takes c1 so
that does not really do much
okay i take him and he's got b5 i guess
b5
b5 queen b6 knight c4 queen takes b5
that
that just works i think so
take queen to b6
knight c4 queen takes b5
maybe in bishop d3 then huh
yeah wait i have no other square anyway
so let's do it
sometimes you just spend time on moves
that are forced and this is a
typically a useless procedure
so yeah take bishop d3
looks a bit awkward
kind of have to do it
knight c3 is the idea
at the end b7 does hang right
[Music]
um
ouch ah no
ah
oh man i completely outplayed this guy
and overlooked this simple tactic i mean
here white is just outplayed i think
he's not okay so there was a tactic and
the tactic
was e4 not c5 though i don't think c5 is
good
but it turns out it's okay still for
what and that's very interesting
i i've already felt that white is in in
trouble here
queen d3 is strong it turns out
ah okay so let's go from there um
i went knight a4
a5 so queen d3 okay
queen d3 intending to take
that strong yeah yeah what can you do
yeah so if i have to play g6 this is
really bad
and then he's got queen b3 also
okay so that was very very bad yeah
just this thing here i kind of felt his
outplayed a little bit but
that's only the case here after bishop
g3 and that is
something where black is starting to be
better but queen c6
is actually dicey because of the move
form e4
not not easy to play so that actually
prepares
knight e5 so as i said the tactics
there could be something tactical and
this is the tactical thing
yeah it's good for white i mean it's not
like winning also but it's it's good for
white
so but he only found c5 and this must be
must be fine right this
and this must be just better right
so rook a8 is right
and then he stumbled into that thing
yeah yeah
bishop e4 is still a game
but here bishop e5 i cannot stop that
move
really i didn't see it at all
i cannot stop that move
i mean it's the kind of thing i mean he
did not plan that but it worked out
so bishop d3
so rook a8 is right here it's not
actually very trivial
so that after this i can go to a6
and now there's not this discovery can
be answered with bishop takes f3
that's technically very demanding
interesting game
i i thought that i was kind of out
playing him a little bit on the queen
side but
um there were tactical resources that
were strong for white in this case
here queen d3 even was probably winning
it was just um that's just bad
interesting interesting game
okay guys thanks for watching